tell us a little bit more about this
partnership because I would say the uber
app is pretty good why do you need
anything else new rap is great the
reason you need something else is
because you want to find people where
they have an intent to travel or to go
somewhere so when you're in facebook
Messenger your kind of talking to your
friends and they're saying hey let's go
to dinner tonight and here's a location
then the experience ends for facebook
Messenger there and then they flip out
in through the uber app so I'm going to
take them in partnership with facebook
and go right from that experience to
getting an uber inside the facebook
Messenger thread and then you're going
to get updates about your ride in that
facebook Messenger thread so you never
have to leave there how does the
partnership work though who makes money
here well hopefully what happens is that
they get ray rupp they ride on uber
maybe that's our first experience of
their second they keep riding on uber
and that's how everyone makes my why is
Facebook want to do it because the
facebook Messenger experience which by
the way 700 million people in the world
use every month they want to have a more
rich experience for their riders so it
just makes Facebook sticker they're not
taking part of your revenue weird like
rush hour financials but but what is
interesting is when you see in the
future is you'll be able to see where
all your friends are on your way to
restaurants so you know when you go to
restaurant in the one person's there
because the whole party is not there no
one's going to be that guy or gal
anymore i was going to show up at the
same time because you're gonna be able
to track everyone inside messenger on
their way to restaurant this is your
vertical at uber you control you drive
the partnerships at this point everybody
wants to do business with uber talk
about how big your partnership business
is so I started at the company about two
and a half years ago I have one
partnership guy who'd sort of dropped
out of college and said I'm going to go
work in uber so i started with him now
i've got about 60 people around the
world in five continents working on all
kinds of partnerships with baidu search
in in china with tata motors in india
with Starwood in the u.s. American
Express Hilton your percentage of your
revenue comes from these partnerships
well I think you're talking about
getting into double-digit percentages of
these partnerships or and their impact
on our business and they're more
important in countries that are not our
home country when you go to India having
partnership with sort of the local
players they're really matters if you're
double digits what's the rate of growth
it's grown it's grown as fast as i could
add people and the faster we can
integrate new technologies the
integrations to make them really slick
you got to spend time on them and we got
to iterate on this facebook thing until
it's really slick when we talk rate of
growth we've got to talk about ubers
growth whether they say there's a burger
is out there you have gotten so big so
fast maybe your competitors are changing
yesterday google announced in 2016 next
year out of alphabet comedy they're
going to be putting out a fleet of
driverless cars and part of the intent
is to compete against you what do you
make of this you know they're an
investor in uber they invest in us to
two years three months ago really yeah
there was big news at the time because
they thought what we did was interesting
Oh interesting that now they're going to
try to do it themselves well I think in
this day and age with companies as big
as they are and as big as we're becoming
there are some areas you compete and
some areas are cooperating so we still
cooperate with them on google maps if
you open Google Maps today you'll see an
uber button there so there's things we
do together the day and that partnership
though in a year when they've got
driverless cars can they say thanks but
no thanks we'll be taking Google Maps
back I guess I could but driverless cars
is a long ways away to get the tech
right to get the regulations right and
in the produce trouble so let me ask the
question a different way could it go the
other way so they're not actually
competing with you but you actually join
out it could be like you always want to
keep your your options open a partner
with companies that are doing
interesting things so you think we'll do
that you've hired some robotics experts
from Carnegie Mellon tell me about that
why what are they going to do with their
focused on in Pittsburgh and it's a
great team you meet these people they're
really some of the best in the world
they're going to make sure that in a
driverless car world that will happen at
some point that we are a leader there
and so robotics is a part of making the
driverless car work it seems like your
business model could change though if
you end up with a fleet of cars who owns
them oh it's a great question i mean i
think you know what we would prefer to
be a lot of options for driverless cars
and be a rich competitive market there
and then we'll have them on our system
and will have different ownership malls
but it's so far away i'm not thinking
about that on the ownership model front
I think about lift I think about via you
want to buy those uh we haven't done
these those kind of M&A things because
we uh we won good one with it when we
can think that you always good but for
us it's about building and sort of
devoting ourselves to making sure that
we're the best in the world of what we
do so every day I'm trying to do that